la crisis en líbano ha llevado al
presidente a considerar que es momento
de un cambio en el sistema político y
que ese cambio sea declarar un estado
laico porque creo que solo un estado
laico es capaz de proteger y preservar
el pluralismo en verdadera unidad
prometo convocar a un diálogo que
incluya autoridades sectarias y líderes
políticos para llegar a una fórmula que
sea aceptada por todos y que se plasme
las oportunas reformas constitucionales
el problema no son los criterios
religiosos que rigen al estado y sus
instituciones el dilema en líbano es que
el poder se reparte en 18 comunidades
religiosas el presidente siempre debe
ser cristiano
el primer ministro musulmán sunita y el
portavoz o presidente del parlamento
musulmán chiíta este modelo que entró en
vigencia en 1990 poniendo fin a una
guerra civil de 15 años provoca
divisiones dificultando la formación de
gobiernos y generando falta de consenso
a la hora de impulsar cualquier reforma
a los ojos de los libaneses esta es la
causa de que casi la mitad de la
población viva en la pobreza y que el
país tenga una deuda equivalente a más
del 170 por ciento de su producto
bruto además de deficiencias en los
servicios básicos cansados de la
situación los ciudadanos se han volcado
a las calles y en menos de un año han
provocado la caída de dos gobiernos